how's it going everyone and welcome to
the house - this is a flash game it was
recommended by you guys and I listened
to you guys I'm not a good youtuber
anyway the legend has it that there's a
house in a small town that has been
closed it's a house belong to wealthy
family but then one day all family
members
father mother daughter and made
committed suicide wow they really like
thinking suicide commit incest her from
that time the neighbors have closed the
house for good as they believe the house
where all family committed suicide is
Kurd I don't know if I read that
correctly some said that they have
earned now women screaming noise from
the house yes no one dares enter the
house are you I mean are you someone
said that you heard wings me no one dare
to enter the house are you am i what am
i [ __ ] what
no we're not gonna skip the intro okay
let's go huh
[Music]
let's go smoke knocking hey
oh sweet
you're not inside Al's loading first
[Music]
September 19 1964 I can feel something
strange in how like actually feel it
since the first day I came from where I
guess there's made I'm afraid of that
thing should I quit thanks for it
sick of the photo beautiful you sign
super weird face super weird face -
super weird face 3 right-click alright
doesn't work great nothing creepy about
this house so far I don't see what's so
scary
okay so let's go
I was a quick game I'm [ __ ] leaders
quick games yes you know like everything
yes I'm already stuck looking at your
photo what else do you want there's
blood on the door I don't like blood
there's always blood everywhere in these
freakin games why blood why couldn't be
like mustard or something would have
been a lot more convenient that mustard
on the wall I mean it's easier to remove
mustard from the wall instead of we're
removing blood so I shouldn't use so
much on the wall I'm just saying you
should quit you should quit your job
what was that
someone upstairs the [ __ ] I use so mad
brah come on
yeah I looked at the photo three times
five whoa there's blood coming to the
photo there's totally blood there I'm
why not mustard okay sorry
under the bed hey this is creeping me
out I'm getting goose bumps
okay quick anything else I got I got I
got I can make me [ __ ] like it thing
million times words okay there's
something I'm missing
I wasn't scared oh great what what what
do you want from me mr. note
daughter's euro [ __ ] quickly five
times I'm excited twenty times sometimes
she talked alone sometimes she laughed
at night and sometimes she called
somebody good times
sometimes friendly this game wants me to
click everything like five times until
something happens
[Music]
ah
stop doing that she's not horny he's not
first up they're not 500k Oh bathroom
mousse in the shower Oh who's in the
shower
Oh Holy Bible holy [ __ ] yeah get it
toilet no no I don't get anything
there's definitely gonna be a penis
monster in there if I could give enough
time holy bible holy bible
Holy Bible I don't mean it's awesome
it's definitely gonna be there cooking
everything like a boss ha ha his ready
for the penis monster ha ha oh man oh
man oh man I love I love splashing water
so beautiful I do this at home this is
me in bathroom by the way I just pull
the curtains back and forth back and
forth read the Holy Bible no just don't
read it just look at it again
[ __ ] there's a lot of thunder outside I
can't go back no I can't come on stupid
carrot down maybe there's something a
quick insight no there's something I'm
missing period there someone seriously
missed the toilet what I don't know
don't judge me
read the whole of Apple now what the
only get me like that Holy Bible don't
look at me like that
I always win staring contest I think
you're tough huh hmm
you think I don't win this shining home
I'm sorry Congress would you guys I
think I winged [ __ ] whatever seriously
what if I was to do Wow click the
salient times what do you want from me
this game ladies a certain order I have
to pick it
oh I get it water comes first then the
bathroom thingy and then the Holy Bible
is obvious oh great right there [ __ ]
race
it's gonna click this a million [ __ ]
times [ __ ] something better I don't
understand oh [ __ ] look okay great
oh there's blood coming [ __ ] perfect
period couldn't you couldn't be period
ah good I missed I spelled there's a
note
I'm true to size from what I have done
to our kid please jump a we have a kid
oh who are you You're not sorry not
sorry
I trusted you
I read your now than everything come on
come on eat it oh [ __ ] there wasn't
anything what are you doing there brah
no there's nothing normal
I mean weird about that
God give me [ __ ] man oh stop doing
that please